well a million doses by September is
really exciting but my question is well
what happens after September because a
million doses is just the starting point
the UK population if we worked on the
number of people who have flu vaccine
plus essential workers police fire NHS
workers social care workers let's just
say we needed 20 million people to be
vaccinated and we needed to do that
twice that's 40 million doses well how
long does it make take to make the first
million and if we had a million doses a
week that's 40 weeks just to get our
vaccine so expectations of huge
quantities of vaccine have to be
tempered with realism is there a danger
that some countries with certain
political leadership will attempt to
corral the vaccine for their own
population to stop it being exported and
shared around the world everybody will
want to protect their own population and
there will be rationing a lot will
depend of course on the behavior of the
producers now the producers may define
how they handled all requests from their
customers and they may come to review
that they will provide their vaccine
equitably amongst not just those who can
pay high prices but those who can't
afford high prices so the world has to
come to some conclusion about how when
this wonderful resource becomes
available we will share it in some parts
of the world people will see it as a
matter of national security and will
slap an export ban on a vaccine that is
made within those borders I think that's
a very real fear and I have that fear
also that countries will say we want to
protect our own population first and
they will not allow export even if the
company producing it wanted to export it
so the behavior of governments
actually here maybe more penetrant in
the availability of vaccine than the
behavior of the producers we have our
own sage committee in this country how
good a concept is it for for channeling
scientific advice to those who really
need it at the top I think that it is a
good way to bring together the best
possible experts on a topic that you can
find I think that there's no reason
actually to keep it secret I do believe
that in a world that we share now
transparency is more important than
secrecy and if people worry that they're
going to be pestered well they don't
have to answer the phone and they don't
have to accept every invitation to give
an opinion so I think the process is the
right process to get the best advice I
think it should be the best scientific
advice and it's then up to the
government to decide what to do with
that scientific advice we are all as a
nation being asked to make a sacrifice
by staying at home based on the
scientific evidence we've repeatedly
told but it's very difficult to know
what that genuine Evans is what what is
being heard within that room now I agree
with you that we do have the right to
know from whom the advice is coming why
should we not know the answer that we're
protecting their privacy I think is no
longer a realistic one my name is in the
telephone book why would we want to have
such secrecy that you can't know who is
helping shape these decisions that are
affecting our lives it's impossible to
ignore that on the 31st of January were
leaving the European Union how much of a
distraction do you think brexit was to
the government in those key early weeks
all I ever read about in the newspapers
was brexit and preparing for brexit I do
know that it was very difficult to get
nan Brett
pieces of work taken through because of
areas where I was involved since leaving
the Department of Health I've been very
involved in polio eradication on a
global scale and it was difficult to get
the UK's interest on just a very small
piece of work because it was always
being set aside for brexit if my one
small experience has anything to go by
it was very difficult to get non brexit
in issues to be given priority